today I want to tell you about the weight
to be from the 2nd generation of immigration
and the pressure we feel on our shoulders constantly
to tell you
not 1 day ago until I
think of this weight I have carried on my shoulders since birth
it can be 1 weight that is put on your shoulders in a direct way
by your parents
it can be 1 weight that is put on your shoulders unconsciously
because you are aware of all the sacrifices
that made your family
to get to where you are
and so you feel
and just to clarify what we call 2nd generation
it is the children who are born or
grow up in 1 country where their parents were not born
before the haters fall on me
I am very proud of my origins
I am very proud of the sacrifices my parents made
and I am aware of all the opportunities that it has opened up for me in my life
and we will not be blind about the pressure it imposes
that there is so much expectation
so much pressure on these immigrant children
from childhood
you must be a model student at school
because we want to give a good picture of his parents' country of origin
not to be left out
not to be stigmatized
so we carry the weight of our parents' culture on our shoulders
because often we are in the minority
and so the only image your comrades will have of your community will be you
you must be 1st in the class
because we also have to show that we are intelligent
and in addition to all this,
even at home you have to be a model student
that is to say,
that we are irreproachable
so you have to be 1st in class at school
and at home 1 model child
we are really expected to be irreproachable
in any case from the culture where I come from
there is really the emphasis on being an exemplary child
then maybe it is related to the fact that I am 1 girl
and that I was raised in 1 culture
very very traditional
then 1 time we work
you have to be ambitious enough to
have 1 level of income that allows
to take care of his whole family and parents
and at the same time be 1 model mother
1 traditional woman at home
i.e.
taking care of your home
take care of your children take care of your parents
because in traditional cultures
or at least in the culture I come from
there is really a lot of expectation on the child
last pressure I feel too
is the fact of integrating myself enough into the culture of the host country
because I want to fit in I don't want to be left out
and this is the country where I was born after all but at the same time
when I am at home my parents who were not born in this culture
have their own culture and to belong also to this world
I have to adapt to this culture
and so I really feel like I belong to 2 different worlds
and so there is really this double expectation to integrate into the 2 cultures
and finally I feel like I never succeed
because in fact neither culture has been instilled in me entirely
sometimes we get lost in it because we have so many codes to adopt
to learn to master
there are so many paradoxes in the image that we have to send home
the image that must be sent back to the outside
to give you 1 example in fairly traditional cultures
you are supposed to be a woman who respects her elders
who does not impose his ideas but who submits to the rules of his tradition
while outside your home
what is valued in his parents' welcoming culture
in any case here in France
and independence
is to have opinions
is to impose oneself in the world of work
because otherwise we simply get crushed
there is so much 1 paradox between the 2 worlds it becomes exhausting by